[Music]
Razi Jalil loved life being surrounded
by her adoring family meant everything
to her she was a very strong loving very
caring woman she always taught us me and
my siblings always to think of others
she all would have had other people's
interest at heart dying of Kovan 19
gasping Ferrer isolated and alone would
have destroyed rasa as much as the virus
that killed her shumsa walked her mother
into a waiting ambulance when she fell
ill it would be the last time she saw
her mother alive it's not being able to
go and see her even if you just go and
sit with her it's it's a big big thing
just to be able to sit and comfort her
you couldn't do that can anything
prepare you for the loss of a loved one
it's a big hole in your life this
disease is doubly cruel it robs you of
life and your loved ones of a chance to
hold you and say goodbye
you've never been given the opportunity
to say goodbye to your mother that must
have been really difficult and like my
daughter was there she is upset I can't
can't hug her can't comfort her that was
heartbreaking
this family's agony is being repeated in
homes right across the country because
Razia is just one of the 10,000 people
who have lost their lives to covert 19
the first recorded virus death was here
at the Royal Berkshire Hospital in a
little over five short weeks we have
passed a grim milestone a woman in her
70s died on the 5th of March a day after
being admitted within a week nine others
wouldn't make it out of hospital a month
later the death toll stood at almost
5,000 and now less than 40 days are for
the first coronavirus death on the
British soil
the figure has reached over 10,000
people that significance was not lost on
the health secretary we joined the list
of countries who have seen more than
10,000 deaths related to coronavirus
while so many families still mourn their
loved ones now may not be the time to
ask difficult questions about government
strategy except one what bereaved
families will want to know is if more
lives could have been saved
I think I can look at whether the
decisions about at what point we would
into lockdown
at what point we moved away from doing
the case detection and quarantine of
contacts was that done at exactly the
right time and I say these are always
questions that are easy to answer in
hindsight but I think certainly some
people in the public out community would
say a more aggressive approach to the
contact tracing and testing quarantine
of contacts at the beginning and keeping
out up for longer might have made a
difference but I have to say in the 2009
h1n1 flu pandemic people criticized the
government for the reverse for hanging
on too long to the strategy it's not
easy and that difference might have
prevented heartache for families like
Rogers it's really hard for any one of
us to truly comprehend the sheer scale
of this pandemic the number of lives
lost here in the UK try and imagine this
stadium on
matchday packed with fans full of energy
noise and life now think of 10,000 empty
seats each one of these representing a
life lost a life taken or a life cut
short football grounds will fill up
again and slowly very slowly after this
pandemic is finally over our lives will
begin to return to normal but for at
least 10,000 families their lives will
never be the same again
Ashish Joshi sky news